bonjour Martin Hirsch vous êtes ancien
président d'Emmaüs vous êtes ancien au
commissaire aux solidarité des actives
vous êtes aussi président de l'Agence du
service civique et si vous êtes
aujourd'hui à 50 ans Yvelines c'est à
l'occasion des Journées RSE
Responsabilité Sociétale des Entreprises
qu'est-ce que vous avez envie de dire
aux entreprises il y a un mot que vous
avez dit lors de la conférence vous
allez dire en France ça bouge pas assez
vite oui alors c'est pour ça que c'était
intéressant d'avoir dans la salle et moi
j'ai pas fait un discours uniquement
vers les entreprises d'ailleurs c'est un
discours qui nous concernait j'allais
dire tous les acteurs des élus aux
entreprises en passant par les acteurs
sociaux en passant j'allais dire par
les personnes elles-mêmes qui peuvent
être impliquées dans ces programmes de
ce de dire que
il y avait des modèles économiques qui
pouvaient fonctionner qui pouvaient
répondre à la fois aux besoins de celles
et ceux qui
font ont des difficultés d'accès aux
services comme de celles et ceux qu'on a
des difficultés de l'emploi
ce qui impose de monter des partenariats
comme on ne mentait pas auparavant c'est
à dire à partir du système où une
entreprise fait son business puis
ensuite se dit il me reste un peu
d'argent je vais en donner une petite
part de ce qui me reste pour telle ou
tel projet non c'est pas cela c'est
comment j'inclus dans mon projet
économique le fait de bien satisfaire
des besoins sociaux qui ne seront pas
satisfaits autrement en cette période de
crise est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que les sociétés en font plus ou alors
justement du coup elle restreignent un
peu leur budget et elle se tourne moins
vers tout ce qui est de notion de
solidarité citoyenne alors justement
effectivement quand on voit
sur les systèmes classiques qui sont
uniquement de mécénat ou de dos je pense
que les entreprises n'en font pas plus
mais du coup on vient les voir et ce que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure c'est un
modèle dans lequel
ça ne leur coûte pas
c'est pas leur dire donnez-nous quelque
chose c'est juste organisez-vous pour
avoir on dit un business model un modèle
économique qui vous permet de satisfaire
des besoins sociaux sans vous couper un
bras ou un doigt de pied ou un orteil
voilà donc ça il y a effectivement un
intérêt des entreprises pour ce genre de
projets un bien-être des salariés
l'intérêt oui au sein de l'entreprise
l'intérêt ça peut être d'abord de pas se
couper de sa population
si vous voulez quand
une grande partie de la population est à
quelques euros près elle se coupe d'un
certain nombre d'opérateurs
d'entreprises etc qui ne sont plus
accessibles qui ne sont plus dans le
même monde ah donc ça c'est quand même
un petit problème la deuxième chose
c'est effectivement
une implication des salariés sur des
projets qui les réconcilient les gens
sont pas mauvais donc qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent ils veulent avoir à la fois
l'esprit d'initiative et puis en même
temps essayer de faire le bien voilà
donc ils ont pas envie d'un côté de
faire quelque chose ou il satisfont leur
esprit d'initiative et puis
éventuellement le soir ils vont aller
faire le bien en donnant la soupe
populaire donc ça réconcilie voilà ça
lutte contre la schizophrénie chaque
individu il a schizophrénie des
organismes vous dites ça ne coûte rien
malgré tout moi je pense que ça coûte
quand même du temps on voit ici c'est
surtout des grandes entreprises qui
viennent exposer leurs projets de RSE
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
justement que ça concerne plutôt les
grands groupes et pas forcément les TPE
ou les PME parce que ça prend du temps
parce que ça prend un engagement parce
qu'il faut des hommes derrière aussi
pour mettre ça en place oui la question
se pose pas exactement dans les mêmes
termes ce que vous répondra le directeur
d'un TPE c'est de la responsabilité
sociétale j'en fais 24 heures par jour
et effectivement il sera pas confronté
exactement
au même chose mais oui ça prend du temps
mais regardez
d'abord on a toujours du quoi quand on
le veut on peut trouver du temps
ça vaut le coup et
la le prétexte temps pas quand c'est
utile voilà moi j'étais bénévole dans
des associations pendant longtemps en
ayant des boulots sur lequel normalement
on n'a pas le temps d'être bénévole bon
ben on prend le temps dans un article du
Monde vous avez dit il y a semi social
ne peut pas être un gadget aujourd'hui
dans le gouvernement héro il y a un
ministre économie sociale et solidaire
Benoît Hamon vous dites c'est une bonne
chose
oh ben ça dépend ce qu'il a envie de
faire mais je pense que le
l'idée d'avoir mis ce secteur là dans le
ministère des Finances en se disant
c'est pas simplement le social qui vient
de mort ou les mollets de l'économie
mais c'est le ministère économique qui
transforme de l'intérieur c'est plutôt
une bonne chose oui une dernière
question concernant la jeunesse vous
avez parlé de colère aussi par rapport
au fait qu'on fait peut-être pas assez
pour les jeunes et notamment les
entreprises vous êtes président
actuellement de l'Agence du service
civique donc vous vous organisez vous
pouvez organiser la vie des jeunes entre
entre 16 et 25 ans leur proposant
justement de rendre de rendre service il
faut que les entreprises fassent plus
pour les jeunes
elles peuvent pas donner des opérations
par local peut choisir à la fois les
jeunes au pas les bonnes formations et
les bonnes qualifications pour être
employables et à la fois je suis
malthusien pour les prendre en
alternance par exemple voilà faut
choisir le discours et moi je recommande
de prendre le discours qui consiste à
dire oui
votre responsabilité c'est à la fois de
dénoncer un système de formation qui
serait cloisonné hors de l'entreprise
elles l'ont dit elles ont même obtenu
des entreprises viennent à l'école il
faut maintenant qu'elles acceptent que
les jeunes viennent à l'école même si
elles n'ont pas tout à fait besoin de
celui-là à ce moment-là voilà mais on le
prend et on le forme et qu'est-ce qui
bloque qu'est-ce qui fait que les
entreprises c'est investissent pas
autant sur les jeunes qu'elle doit tout
le monde sait que bœuf effectivement
comme la jeunesse passera
en les reprendra plus tard si vous
voulez on
note l'une des pathologies de notre
système on s'est concentré je dirais sur
le segment de la population que la
productivité la plus forte c'est-à-dire
au milieu de la vie active et on a les
laisser passer les bords à la fois les
seniors et les jeunes merci d'avoir
répondu merci beaucoup